all right
good evening everyone and welcome to
tonight's episode of beginner breakdown
as always my name is alex mullery and i
am excited to be doing this lesson today
we're going to be talking about rooks
and i've found that
of all the pieces be it the queen the
pawns the bishop the knight um even the
king
i think the rooks are one of the pieces
that's a little harder to get adjusted
to i believe yasser sarwan
said that he used to have clumsy rooks
and he would intentionally trade them
off for some minor pieces so that he
could feel better about what he was
playing with so i thought tonight we
would start with that
i'm planning to do a small series on all
of the pieces kind of introducing us to
each one some of their fun little quirks
and the individual things they do
and we are going to get started with the
rook here
so just the real basics right if for
those everybody here should know but if
you don't the rook moves
along all of the vertical and horizontal
lines so no diagonals no weird night
jumps
um
but it's a very powerful piece
however like we said it can be a little
clumsy if you don't know exactly how to
use it
for instance
let me give a question to the audience
what would you say is the rook's
favorite phase of the game so like
opening middle game end game which when
are rooks the best
yeah in the end game rooks control a lot
of space and they're just very very good
at helping pawns get home and stopping
the advance of opposing pieces
however because they're powerful right
some beginners make the mistake of
wanting to play them really early right
so i'm sure you've seen stuff where
beginners will like bring out their
queen right away and go for something
really aggressive
generally this isn't a good idea because
even though the queen is a very powerful
piece
uh it doesn't have the support it needs
from the rest of your pieces in your
setup to get started early in the game
you need to give it a little support and
the same is with the rooks so
has anyone ever encountered a game that
went something like this
yeah i think a lot of us have seen these
games some of us have played this game
where a beginner will open up by pushing
one of these side pawns
with the goal of getting their work out
early right it makes sense from a very
basic logic
this is a powerful piece i'm going to
slide it up and over and i'm going to
make some nice threats
really in the opening it's going to just
get in your way
and so if you see this what i always do
is something like d5 and then they
continue their plan not noticing the
discovery
and you just want to rook
so
always be aware of that
rooks do much better later in the game
in the middle game they start to shine
because one they allow castling so your
king can get to safety and your rooks
can start to move towards the files and
then in the end game again they control
a lot of space
one of the key ideas for rooks is
that they like to have an open file and
when i say an open file i mean a file
where there are no pawns
uh in the way right it's just a whole
long line the ranks are these
horizontals on the board and the files
are the verticals
so in this position what's the best move
for white
what might you do
how come
yeah we have rooks here and we want to
open up this file and funny enough in
this position
the computer actually thinks black's
best move is to play e5
instead of capturing this pawn back in
like maintaining material uh because
we're going to be able to hold on to
this pawn
black is much happier leaving this rook
out of the game because if the rook
invades it's actually a really big
problem
uh if they try the natural just
recapturing how would you continue now
yeah
and this is our second principle so if
you have rooks there's two really basic
things you want to remember one they
like these open files
um anytime there's not pawns in the way
it's going to really benefit a rook
second thing is they love the seventh
rank or the second right depending on
which side you are
and the reason for this is because this
is where the pawns start so they're
going to be able to eat a lot of the
ponds and put a lot of pressure as you
can see right now the other reason is
because usually the king's gonna stay
back here for most of the game and if
you can get a rook on the seventh it's
gonna inhibit the king ever escaping or
it's at least gonna make it harder
so the game could continue something
like this
black wants to defend their pawn
and
third kind of key idea here another good
move
any suggestions here
double up the rooks
uh so putting the rooks either on the
same file or the same rank is always
really strong because they support each
other
one and just defending each other but
also they can then put a lot of pressure
on whichever square they're aimed at and
this is the same with any pieces like in
a battery formation like a bishop and a
queen or two rooks here but just
remembering that's amazing so one looks
like open files
so open up the files
two looks like the seventh rank three
rooks like to be doubled and if you can
if you can get doubled rooks on the
seventh then it's about lights out so
keep those things in mind and that's uh
gonna help you out one more last note
about this position
if black decided to take with this rook
here
and try and keep the file closed it
doesn't work because now this pawn hangs
and your rook is going to slide over to
e1 and again we're going to have the
same really nice scenario
okay another really basic piece it'll
get a little more advanced as we go but
i want to start out with the basics is
this two rooks versus a king idea
i was teaching this to a kids beginners
class this weekend and some of them were
falling into some traps and just
mistakes so i wanted to at least go over
the basic idea
but the first step and this is really
with any piece checkmates um but this in
particular shows a really good example
is you want to create a box it's what i
call it create a wall whatever you want
to call it but we want to make a box
that stops the opposing king from having
as much space
so after the move rook to a4 we
basically cut the board in half and this
king is never going to be able to move
forward
king moves to the side and we now use
our second rook to make the box smaller
and we're going to keep encroaching on
this space and keep trying to push all
the way to the very end until we get a
checkmate
now at this point
the problem with the rooks that doesn't
happen with the queen is the king can
attack the rooks right uh because the
queen exerts pressure on the diagonals
the king can never approach her so it's
a little more simple to get a checkmate
with a queen although there are greater
stalemate risks
but with the rooks you have to be
careful so in this position what would
you play if you have the white pieces
rook a5 okay so this is
an okay move but i actually think
there's a better one
the reason i don't love rk5 is it's
still going to get the job done
eventually
but
our end goal is to keep making this box
smaller and as long as these rooks are
actually connected here they're in each
other's way
so normally it's a good thing to have
the rooks connected right you want them
doubled because it gives a lot of power
to what they're aiming at
in this case
uh we don't need to do that um sorry
yeah uh e5 did you say
b5 yes that's going to be the best move
uh an arcane doctrine he said doesn't
you mean the other rook that's a
possibility this is another move here
uh if we put the other rook to a5 and
when we're doing notation or clarifying
if i wanted to be really precise i would
say
the work from h to a5 or work from a to
a5 something like that
in this case if we put this rook it's
going to be a similar problem
we've
just kind of created the same issue but
now the rooks are on the same line it's
not as bad because they're not actually
in the way of moving forward but it is a
bit of a waste of a move i think
instead b5
uh like you corrected
this is a great idea we're switching our
work to the other side of the board and
the king now has to walk all the way
back over and actually there just isn't
enough time um we're just going to be
able to checkmate by this kind of ladder
pattern right one step at a time
lowering the box
something else you don't want to do that
some people will do is in like this kind
of situation they don't actually
understand
the goal and so they might just come
over here
and keep trying to call check
with the wrong rook
something else you got to be aware of
right this is never going to help us we
need to actually keep forcing the king
to the edge
so something like this and hopefully you
understand the principle here nope
not the right move there
questions about that it's a it's a more
basic concept but this is true if you
have a queen and a rook or two rooks
but it's just a super super helpful
thing
okay
let's move on uh to now something a
little more tricky this is this happens
a lot and one of the reasons i think
it's important to talk about the rooks
and why i wanted to do this before i
talked about any other other piece
is because you end up with a lot of end
games at all levels but beginner as well
where there's just like a rook and a
pawn or two on the board most of the
pieces are cleared one side has an
advantage and they're going to be able
to use a piece like a rook or maybe it's
a few rooks but
in this case it's a rook versus a pawn
in this example
uh
our
our job is white is to stop this pawn
from promoting because if this pawn
promotes
it's going to be probably a queen
and we are going to have to
either
keep our rook and risk losing the game
or trade it away and make it a draw
so if you're in this position with white
what would be your strategy to stop the
pawn
how would you try and win this game
um
yeah anybody feel free to shout it out
what might you do
[Music]
d7 we have suggestion rook e7 um
we can call check let's look at e7 first
really quick
we can call check really for the entire
game um
we can keep doing this
but black is again
happy for a draw here so that's not
going to gain us any progress
um
king to d7
all right i will probably
advance my king
preparing to defend my pawn
how would you continue
all right
oh sorry
here
okay uh i guess i will go here
so that's good so i've lost the ability
to come back and defend your rooks cut
me off so in that case i might have to
go here
keep the pawn safe
okay
yeah and now once again you're
threatening to just mate me
uh so i have to move
oh you could even better at this point
you can just check and we're going to
win the pawn
that's i so i think there's lots of ways
to win this um
here's what my advice is if you're in
this type of situation i think the
easiest way to do it and again there's
you can do it in a lot of ways
i would start
by cutting off the king
one of the things that makes the rook so
powerful is it controls this whole
entire line
and it literally just cuts across the
board and says you can never move here
if i don't let you
so in this case what is black to do
because there's a big problem
if
black tries
pushing the pawn so let's say a5
and
in this case i don't need to do anything
with the rook so i'm just going to
probably move my king
and if you continue pushing the pawn
then
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move away and attack it once your king
is too far so you can't defend it
if you push the pawn out if you if you
move the king i'm just going to take the
palm
and if you push the pawn then i'm gonna
get behind it
so the key is i keep the king trapped
and if you commit to pushing it too far
i can just attack and go behind that's
the first strategy but if you play
passively and decide okay i'm never
gonna actually
move the pawn i'm just going to dawdle
around right you have to be the one to
stop me because it's going to be a draw
otherwise
so let's say so a5 and let's say king
a7
what might you do here well here's what
i would do
i'm going to move my king closer sort of
like what we did last time and i'm going
to create checkmate threats
so in this case
your king can't move this way you only
have either move away or advance the
pawn
if you move away well thanks for making
my life really easy that's the game
if you move the pawn
then what would i do
yeah the same thing we just looked at
right i can attack the pawn now because
your king's too far to defend it and if
you push i'm just going to go right
behind
in this case it's actually checkmate uh
so if you try to get out of checkmate
i'll take it and then i'll just have my
king and rook and uh we'll look at the
king and rook
uh how to win with this in a moment but
i want to look at a few more things with
the king and the pawn so again hopefully
that made sense but the main principle
there's lots of ways to do it but what i
think is the easiest
i advocate for
a version of chess for beginners just
and really for anybody called no stress
chess
there's lots of ways to solve this
problem
i think the easiest one is i'm just
going to stop your king
if you push the pawn i'm just going to
wait
until i can attack it so that you can't
defend
and then i'll get behind it and win it
and if you decide to instead just kind
of dawdle around with your king
then
i'm going to put a mating thread on the
board and then i'm going to take the
pawn anyway
okay
let's make this a little trickier
now
the pawn's one square away from
promotion so instead of being all the
way back here now the pawn's ready to
become a queen
how would you
win this game as white
yeah if it's blacks to move then they're
just making a queen
so then white's losing
okay so yeah this is a big question
we have the a file as an option and we
could also go to g1 to stop the pawn
here but you want to go to a1 or a8
is there a reason you pick this one over
g1
much time
yeah exactly so in uh there's no
pressure right on a eight uh i'm
threatening to take your pawn and the
king actually just can't defend it so
i'm gonna win it you either push and i
take it or you move the king and i take
it
here let's say you're playing as black
now and your opponent doesn't understand
this principle that rooks generally are
going to want to be behind the pawns
whichever way the pawn is pushing the
rook want to be behind it whether it's
your own pawn or an opponent's
so in this case
if you're playing and your opponent does
something like this how can black fight
to make this a draw
yeah we're going to move closer to the
pawn
i'm going to come here and attack it i
can't do this
so if i come and attack it like this
and now there's nothing left i can
either take it now and accept the draw
after king takes or i can run away and
let you promote and it's going to be the
same
so instead uh if here
uh or sorry
yeah if you come closer the other thing
i can do is i could start trying to
check you
and that'll work to a point right i can
keep tracking you that's fine
but
but then i have to remember wait i'm
trying to win this game
i don't have a way to do that now um
because i've lost my ability to come get
behind the pawn
so this is also going to be a draw
but in this case we actually want to win
and to do that we just get behind the
pawn put on some pressure
now let's escalate it even a little bit
farther
now your pawns close to promotion
but you also have two more pawns over
here we got to be worried about
so what can we do in this position
to uh to win do you think white can
actually win here or is our best hope to
get a draw
okay what would be your method what
would you want to try
okay so again getting behind the pawn
generally seems the best idea
okay
um so let's say here
a7
here
okay
yeah so now you can't take my pawn here
so what do you do now
uh move your king but it's not gonna
work why not
because he can move to king k2 and then
promote and take the
e2
yeah so let's take a look at that so
here the threat is now that he's going
to promote
is there anything we can do now
maybe just
are we
move light to move
well the rip the problem is now if we
take this pawn
okay
we're trying to win oh we're trying to
wait yeah if you do this
if you do this i'm promoting you have to
trade
and uh do you know how to win with two
pawns
this is a very trivial one for black
because all i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
push one and i'm gonna bring the king in
because you can never take this one
exactly my other one's gonna be first
okay so let's jump back a little bit
so the problem is i liked getting behind
the pawn but then moving arcane we gave
black a little bit too much time i think
so
let's look at an alternative first real
quick
if we want to try this way again try and
come from the side this also
isn't
really going to work
because
push the pawn
i'm going to stop it and it's going to
be similar last time
in b3
and you only have
two good options right if you continue
this plan of well i don't know i'm just
going to trade the rook for the pawn
we're going to end up in the same
situation as last time
and now black is easily winning
so instead of doing that
you have to bring the rook back over
and accept that you're going to get a
draw by just checking a bunch
you don't have to check every move like
right in this position i could have
checked but i'm also just stopping the
promotion but as long as you're doing
something that stops the pawn from
promoting it's going to be a draw
but again we don't want to draw we want
to win so rook c1 isn't good enough rook
a yeah
do you have a question no
okay
so here's the idea so king b3 right
looking to promote the pawn
and here's the trick
we're going to call check
and black is now going to be faced with
a bit of a problem
because
if black goes in front of the pawn at
any point what happens
he's stuck the king is stuck and the
pawn is stuck
so an example of that
could be
let's say yeah let's say here yeah king
is stuck in pawn is stuck now the king
can move here
um but as long as we leave this rook
here we're good
so now
we can come mess around with these pawns
with our king
you can do this i guess
but we can kind of guard these pawns
more importantly though is we actually
want to move our king over
and prepare to just mate you
if you move something like that i guess
i can come over but
i believe we're gonna be okay
i'm gonna get my king close enough but
your king can still can't escape
and now my king is doing the job my work
was doing
you can promote if you want
you can push this pawn if you want well
now you have to move
we have to be careful here i actually
don't want to take this pawn because
then i'm going to get into some stamina
situations
but i'm happy to do
in this case i have to figure out
exactly how i would do it i might go
here with the idea that i'm going to
move my king with check
so let's say something like this
move our king with check
it goes here
and now i'm going to move them here to
attack the pawn
if you push i take it
if you don't
then
actually well yeah i can checkmate
anyway um
but yeah it doesn't really make a
difference now you actually can't you
just can't stop checkmate so that's kind
of the special idea is we want to keep
an eye on uh moving our king over and
once our king is doing the job of rook's
doing it's going to clean up the pawns
that are a threat and let the other ones
run so we can get a stalemate and we can
see a similar thing
if you move the king away
right so that was what happens if you
trap the king
if the king comes out
then we have an option we could check
but we're going to do that forever so we
don't want to do that so we're actually
going to go back and threaten the pawn
rook to a8
and the king can come to b2
and we're going to threaten the pawn
again
we're going to move our king in
eventually
keeping it so you can't promote
king comes down to b2 we gotta check
again
king to c1
c8s
we're gonna keep checking
we're gonna keep guarding the pawn
and if they again if they ever go here
then it's gonna be uh
the white just
wins because now our we can just bring
our king in
and we're gonna stop the pawns and we're
gonna get checkmate
however
it is unfortunate but it is true that
this is actually a draw
white if with best play white's not
going to be able to win
because we do have too much to guard
however like we said there's a lot of
traps that black can fall into
so we can stop the pawn in this case we
just can't win but considering that
we're going against three past pawns and
one of them is very close to promotion
this is still an impressive feat for
this rook
so
questions about this end game
king and uh king and rook versus some
pawns
yeah so it's uh just this idea right
we're gonna stop the pawn and we're
gonna check or attack the
pawn if the king ever goes in front then
white wins so the king has to keep
running away and we're just going to
keep doing this
we can bring the king in if we want it
doesn't really matter
as long as we stop the pawn um
we're just going to keep repeating this
forever
does that make sense
so unfortunately white can't win this
yeah unless he goes because there's no
other way to make progress we we don't
have enough time
to
you know guard these pawns and stop
promotion
okay
uh
really important point now we've talked
about what to do in a lot of these
situations
we have king and pawn versus king and a
lot of the time we're going to be able
to win them by getting rid of the pawns
but once we've done that
how do you actually win this end game so
instead of having our second rook here
where we can just keep going up one and
making these lines making the box
smaller with only one rook it's a lot
harder
so
does anyone does everyone in here feel
confident that you can win with a king
in a rook or is anyone not sure
all right nell do you feel like you got
it
what about you
do you know how like do you feel
confident
sure
be pushing the game to the
edge of the board yeah so let's and uh
arcane doctrine dreaded endgame i'm
hoping that i can make this feel a
little better for you right this does
happen
my chess coach when i was first learning
actually taught me when i was in these
type of situations where i was like
going to promote
he said promote to a rook
because if you promote to a queen it's
actually a lot easier to stalemate as a
beginner
so i would give that same advice but you
gotta know how to do it and it's the
idea is very similar
we're gonna start out we're gonna make a
box
same thing as last time
here's the difference uh
why don't you give me a move for black
do you want the king to approach the
rook run away let's approach okay
so now i can't keep making it smaller i
don't have anything else so i need to
bring my king in to support the rook
because again the difference between the
rook and the queen is the rook's not
defended diagonally so the king's gonna
get to us i'll move my king up okay now
where do you want to go
attack i actually think this isn't as
good a move because now i'm gonna slide
over
and now the box is a lot smaller
so now we're working on a box with uh
four dimensions right or four sides this
is the ultimate box we're working
towards and now i know
i am pushing you towards this corner
if you come back and approach
uh i'm going to take this position this
is called opposition arcane doctrine it
is possible to stalemate but it's a lot
harder and i'll show you why when we get
to the edge of the board
um
this is a key position to remember where
we have our kings facing each other and
the rook's just right here this is
called opposition it comes up in a lot
of king and pawn end games but also in
this position
and the important thing is you always
want to be the one to take opposition
you want to be the one to make the move
that puts us in this position
because now we have control
the black king has to move away
so where do you want to move back
diagonal sideways
where would you like to go all right
let's go to g5
so here's the questions i ask myself
i start out i have to make a box
and then i have essentially like three
or four questions the first question is
can i make the box smaller
if i can
unless the king's on the edge of the
board if i can then i do so
in this case can we make the box smaller
yep
we're going to make it one square
smaller
okay uh now where do you want the king
to go
let's have him go back because we don't
want the king doesn't want to be on the
edge of the board let's put him back
uh
in the second case
or in this case again i'm going to ask
can i make the box any smaller
the answer is
okay you say yes
[Music]
yeah so this
so the answer is yes and no right i
can't make it smaller with the rook but
i can actually make it a little smaller
with the king
in this case i'm taking away this square
and this square that the rook aren't
doing so in in a way i am making the box
smaller right
um
but i'm not using the rook so i can't
make the box smaller with the rook my
next question is i'm going to try and
put the king in opposition because that
is again going to remove some of these
squares
okay king moves back again
can i make the box smaller i can so i'm
going to do it
and now black puts their king in
opposition this is the only tricky part
to this whole
end game if you know how to deal with
this you're going to be fine because the
problem is what what move do you play
here
we now have to move our king or our rook
but the box is as small as it can be so
we would much rather black have to move
and we can keep pushing them away
and we can shuffle
around but we're never going to get
anywhere
so go back okay
uh i will go
here
and then
okay
oh
here yeah
all right i'm gonna take opposition
again
so that's one way there's a few methods
to do it what i think is the simplest
way that i know and you can kind of be
fancy with the rook but you do have to
be a little careful is i just do this
thing called triangulation
where essentially what needs to happen
is i need to reach this position with
with white uh not being the one having
to move where black has to move and i do
that by losing a move
so i'm gonna make three moves with my
king while you make two
i'm gonna go to the side whichever way
you go and let's pretend we're not on
the edge of the board here
all right let's actually just go back
i'm just gonna set up something
[Music]
here
okay
so in this position i'm going to
triangulate
i'm going to move my king to the side
and i'm going to move it down and i'm
going to come back and this is going to
take three moves
so if you do something like this
i go back
and now i'm the one who has opposition
and you have to move away there's other
ways to deal with it um
in this case i might go here
if they take opposition i'm just going
to give it to them real quick
you can also back off and then make the
box smaller
there's a lot of ways to do it but
knowing the key of like needing to lose
a move is really helpful
okay but let's get to the edge of the
board so what happens once we push the
king all the way to the edge because
that's like maybe you can figure it out
even if you don't know much of the rest
but let's say we get the king of the
edge of the board
in this case it would actually be matan2
because i would push my king up and then
get checkmate but let's say it's not
that simple
i'm going to go i want black to have
opposition here
or no wait i don't i won't white down my
position here because then it's just
checkmate in one
all right let's just say it's this
position
right to move how do i win this game
i've gotten the king on the edge the
rook is trapping him there what do i
need to do to win this game
any suggestions
um
okay so king in opposition
and um
um
okay like opposition again
now if we keep taking opposition they're
just gonna shuffle back
so we need to do something to make
progress here
okay let's we can make the box smaller
um
five six
six all right
i'll take opposition
um
okay
now it's white to move
we triangulated so they lost opposition
we can make the box smaller
uh we can triangulate here again and
that's actually going to be the key
because if we go here it's just going to
shuffle
but there's kind of two ways to do this
in this position you can either
triangulate
they go to the corner and we checkmate
or
you can also do it like this
we can take
or sorry they go back we can take
opposition and then give it to them
and then what's another way we can lose
a move in this position
without
yeah
rook literally anywhere on this flying
except for here
because their move is going to be the
same
so we just drop back anywhere we want
and this is going to be checkmate
if that's still too confusing
oh real quick arcane doctrine here's the
answer to your question
this is how you make stalemate in this
position
you make the box smaller here
that's the really the only way you can
stalemate this um
so
that's why i think i like this better as
a beginner because there's much it's
much harder to do this naturally and
you're going to know they have no moves
what actually happens more often with
beginners is they'll leave the rook
undefended and then it's just a draw by
insufficient material
if the king doesn't have to be in the
corner though you can also mate in the
middle of the board
and the way to do that is you actually
want them to take opposition because you
want your king to be cutting off these
squares so what i could do
like back here
is after you make this move
i can just wait with my rook
and now if you come back here
it's checkmate
and if you run away i'm going to close
in and offer you the same situation
you run away i'm going to do the same
thing and now you have no option so
that's another way to do it there's lots
of ways to get this ending but
essentially the principle is we're going
to have to lose a tempo whether we do
that by moving the rook one farther back
whether we do that by triangulation
as long as you understand that principle
you'll be good
any questions on the king and rook was
that clear or do people
ever feel good okay so real quick just
running through it one more time
we make a box
we can make it smaller but i'm going to
bring the king in a little bit because i
need my kink to support
we're going to make this box smaller
and anytime we can i'm just happy to
make the box smaller
in this case i can't so i'm going to
move my king closer
when i can take opposition i do so
i'm going to make the box smaller
in this case i can make the box smaller
by taking opposition so i'm going to do
that
and if my opponent ever takes opposition
from me i have options but to me i'm
just going to triangulate
now i could make the box smaller here or
i can make this triangle pattern
and then keep making it smaller once i
have you on the edge of the board
i just have to understand which tempo i
need to get to you at in this case it
works out
and i get a checkmate
any final questions before we move on to
the next thing
okay so i thought we would wrap up
today's lesson we got about i think 20
minutes left with a few different other
checkmating examples
uh
the focus on the rook so here's some
ways that in games
um
i'm glad to hear that helps a lot it's
it's a really good one now
okay so we looked at this last week we
looked at back ranks um and the basic
idea here is the rook and really the
queen as well but the rook especially
because it hits these horizontals
is very useful in this type of position
where the king
is stuck behind either their own pawns
or our pieces are controlling these
squares
um and they only can go to the side
which means we can hit them all the
reason this is such a common position is
because this is like the natural result
of castling so you see it a lot it's
really important to keep an eye out for
this because it happens a lot but the
basic premise is the king cannot move
anywhere except for this rank it could
also be on a file but that's more
unusual right ranks happen when we
castle so we can get this checkmate
because of this principle it actually
opens up some examples so these are
going to be a little more advanced
but here's our first example here
and it is black to move
and using it might not exactly end up in
a back rank but using some of the
principles of back rank we are going to
be able to
win this game
even though we're actually down a queen
for a rook
so what might we do in this position to
gain an advantage here
uh a6 h6 i mean
yeah
yeah bishop h6 check okay
and now black is in a con or sorry
white's in a conundrum
hello liberated toaster
uh because if you move the king
you're getting back cranked right
because of that
you have
really two options you could throw all
of your pieces in the way
uh eventually you're gonna have to throw
the rook in the way anyway so it's
better to just start with that and what
would we do here
with what the bishop or the rook
okay this is a not trivial
decision so let's really calculate this
out
one of these leads to a win and one of
them leads to a draw i believe
um
might even be worse than that
if we take with the rook what is white
going to play
so our work's no longer defended
okay
yeah all right
so we have to be careful of that yeah if
we take with the bishop what is black or
sorry what is white can i play
e
[Music]
uh well there's d8 or b8 or sorry d1 or
b1
so which one
i think is better
yeah i i am curious i don't actually
know if they go
here
they're setting up for a back rank but
unfortunately we don't really have
anything
great to attack maybe in this position
we would just simply play
here
and we're threatening to come down
but i think this is actually going to be
a draw
if they go to d1 it's a similar idea we
can now move the bishop but the problem
is again there's not really a great
discovery idea for it
so maybe it would just be something like
this and we have to repeat
yeah
so unfortunately taking with the bishop
doesn't work funny enough this is
actually the move we take with the rook
and yes our rook hangs but we have a
great follow-up
take
take
check
brutal
and we get win a rook
and a queen for a rook
if you do this unfortunately i can't
back rank you because
i'm pinned but i do win a queen
um and you can't go anywhere else so
does the principle of that one make
sense
let's go to our next example here
black to move
uh bishop d7 check okay
i can't push the pawn because it's
pinned so bishop d7 i will play king to
a5
okay i will block with the bishop
i will take with the king
oh yeah
so check
king
check
um bishop
um
we still have this work here
we have a queen
although it's kind of guarded
wait in that position
yeah so if queen takes this would be
mate and we'll look at that in a second
what if um
now we can move this pawn to block
then you take
the other pawn on which
point uh it's defended
it's okay
we're looking pretty far ahead uh bishop
b3
[Music]
uh our bishop's going to be on d7 in
this variation
and then capture rook b5
bishop
oh oh yeah liberated toaster yeah i
think you've got the final killing blow
so let's take a look at this it's funny
you can actually win this with rook a5
it's a very different checkmate um
but like you actually draw the king out
into the middle of the board this one is
our kind of back rank idea we notice
that the king really is pretty limited
right now and we would love to just
deliver this checkmate
but
the king has an escape square
again this is going to work but it's
going to be weird
i can show you that if you want in a
minute but first we take away the escape
square
king moves up
and now we have all of these squares
covered so we check forcing them to
block
we check again
and if they were to take we take and now
this is maintain
two
so they can't take with the queen
they now block with the pawn and here's
the kicker is yeah liberated toaster you
capture on v5
defended and pinned
so king has to move back and this is a
back rank checkmate
kind of also a ladder mate um
real quick i'll show you this one
because it's funny if you play rook a 8
king comes to b5
now we go bishop d7 king comes to c5
and there's rook to a5 rook sacrifice
check
because if the pawn takes then the queen
bounces to f8
and then to a8
and then to c6 and this is checkmate
really really strange
um that's going to be a lot harder to
calculate for me so i'm going to stick
with the back rank but if you see that
variation you're welcome to use it
all right our third back rank example
here
how should white continue
um
where
uh here i assume
yeah okay queen takes
okay um
i have a move
i might just play like h6 or something
so i'm not yeah unfortunately i have i
have one move there
so that's not going to gain us anything
we're not necessarily losing
but
i think black's in a better position
with these rooks here on the second so
we have to be careful not to give them
too much time
any other suggestions here
okay arcane doctrine rook
uh oh we already looked at d8 yeah so d8
unfortunately doesn't quite work
sorry tracy had an idea
so queen queen bishop
black has a move
so yeah this is unfortunately not quite
fast enough
and now we're going to have to fight
these rooks
yes and a few people have found the
right idea rook e8 doesn't work
because we can
force the queen to go away and we get a
bishop but the bishop's not worth the
rook
plus there's too much trouble but some
people have noticed that you can
actually solve it by reversing the order
we take the bishop first
and the queen
can't take back
because it has to guard this back rank
right
if they take our queen we win the game
so this is actually just really rough
and it's also
well it's not actually it might almost
be a queen trap it's very close i think
the queen's gonna have to run all the
way over here
um
and now we just have this extra bishop
we have a pawn that's ready to promote
so i think actually we can survive this
see really good for the people who found
that one
the other thing to notice in this
position
is this is a little introduction to the
next one is when we have two rooks on
the second
we have to be very careful if this
bishop wasn't here would be in even more
danger because it's at least giving some
defense
but this actually leads into another
kind of rook checkmate called the blind
swine mate
and here's the basic example
some kind of position like this how does
white win here should be fairly
intuitive
okay we take
king has one move
okay king has one move
the other rook comes in if we move this
one back it's just a repeat so this one
comes in
not there that's a loss
or at least a draw maybe i don't know um
and we cover all the squares
so this is the idea of the blind swine
mate it's one of the reasons why having
rooks doubled on the seventh is so
powerful
so let's take a look at one example here
in this position
uh
pieces are about equal but
black is actually really close to
promoting a pawn and getting a queen so
is there a way like right for instance
if we were to take this knight then they
can get a queen so how should white
continue in this position
a blind swine is what this is called so
like swine like pig i don't know where
it gets the name
sacrifice the rook on
um
okay
uh rook takes
so this is
a back rank problem our knights covering
these escape squares
we got to keep that in mind
now we cover all the squares that's
really good so you can't take
so they're gonna have to play something
else uh not really much else to play if
i just move my rook out of the way let's
say threaten your knight
now what
and it's the same pattern and now our
knight's the one controlling this final
square so we get our same blind spot
yeah it's the same exact thing right
exactly so if we take if you promote to
a queen there's no time to do anything
with it because we get this first yeah
so it's a really powerful thing even the
queen is not enough to stop this
look at one more blind swine example
here
black to move
okay and this is right because i mean
doubling up is nice but we don't need to
put pressure here we need to put
pressure here
okay
uh if i take
back rank right we always got to be
watching out for that right even if the
pawns aren't there this is still a
checkmate or well it's it's i mean it's
going to be checkmate yeah it's the it's
the pattern um
okay so we take obviously can't do that
so let's say
rook to e1
um
okay this one's a little different right
because now
they still have an open square so what
can we do here
uh where
yeah so we can't back this one up
because then that leaves us undefended
so like you said rook on g3
yeah and uh we're threatening
well let's see what is the threat let's
say i just push upon
not quite i have an escape here
work on a
third way
over
here yes okay
go back
is it is it
um the queen's about to promote yeah we
got to be careful of this queen
um
let's see
we can we can repeat here if so at very
least we have a draw
um but can we get a win
uh
it's the other one because the knights
protect
our world to the game
that's it
easy to miss but yeah our knight is uh
guarding everything here so we get to
cover everything problem with here is we
lose this square but here it works
really good yeah liberated toaster you
found that as well rook f2 really nice
all right five minutes left let's look
at one more pattern here also really
really cool
um
this one's called anastasia's mate
similar to back rank right these things
we've seen
but it involves a knight uh i guess a
bishop could be here covering these
squares but this is it's at least called
an anastasias when you see this
and yeah this one's not the hard one uh
rook a1 is the idea and it's similar to
a back rank where all of these squares
are controlled but this is another
really useful one because it comes in
handy a few times so let's see
i'm gonna go to example two here first
actually because example one is from a
really cool game
so in this position
keeping in mind our pattern
how can
uh and i'll go back to it real quick
just so we can remind ourselves so we
want to look for this kind of pattern
where the knight is covering these
squares and we're going to be able to
deliver checkmate
so white to move
need a nice check
uh queen
so here's d1 where you want to go here
e8
okay queen e8 um
so i can't take it right you're looking
at this back rank thread
which is nice
but i wonder what i can do instead
maybe something as simple as like
g6 and i think i'm okay
our chat's screaming over here
i have a lot of suggestions here
uh someone is suggesting queen takes h7
but i don't see the follow-up here
i like the little
some of the worst kittens though
[Music]
f7
okay knight e7 so this is check we can't
take uh here
king h8
yeah i know a lot of people are
screaming in the chat it's okay we'll
get there
we're very close we just got to put the
pieces together
bye
i guess we can draw the key
yeah so notice we already have this
position
so if we can open up this pawn and get
the king there it's good so
now we take with the queen this has to
happen after check
and now rook a5 yeah to everyone in the
chat uh
uh
benvar royal fork
uh eigen right i wanna make sure y'all
yeah i saw what you're saying you got it
so this is a really cool one and i want
to show the very end to
a game that uh magnus carlsen played
when he was 12. he played this against
believe the guy's name was john ludwig
hammer or hammer
and uh
magnus seemed to get himself into a bit
of a pickle right this knight has
nowhere to go
um
it's basically trapped the last move
played was rook to e1 trapping this
knight
knight to f4 doesn't work
because of queen to f3
and now we're hitting the rook and we're
hitting the knight a second time so i'm
gonna pick something up
so the knight is trapped but
carlson had thought a little bit ahead
anybody want to find our last solution
today
uh not a5 but queen h5
again brutal out in the middle of
nowhere in this game 12 year old magnus
carlson
just crushes
unfortunately his opponent's dreams
so we stopped the hammering
with rook to h4 anastasia's beautiful
checkmate
yeah queen sacks are fun but those are
some of the basics so again hopefully
we're i wanted to have some fun with
these puzzles but hopefully you
understood kind of the main point is
looking at the rooks
understanding what do they do how do
they move how can we use them rooks
thrive in the end game and somewhat in
the middle game if you can get them to
the open files if you can double them up
because to support each other
um and understand right how to use them
put them behind the past pawns
and use them to slowly encroach space on
the king so again thank you everyone for
joining me
and joining all of us today hope